all right
hey don't mean oh the [ __ ] peed on me
gee says he peed on me he [ __ ] he [ __ ]
all over me
oh that's where he's butthole you
[ __ ] [ __ ] asleep hey how's it
going brush - beautiful
so today I wanted to make a video about
- bird simulator with slippy great
[ __ ] idea
oh Jesus Christ No
[Music]
you [ __ ] coward you [ __ ] toad
Mikey might cheer sleeping you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
literally I want to talk about tuber
simulator the game has been downloaded
more I hear you back there you [ __ ]
okay here's a little pro tip to you if
your toad starts making fart noises
abort mission
anyway you bros have been [ __ ]
incredible beyond my wildest imagination
the game has been downloaded more than
five million times I haven't gotten an
updated number and that's just from a
couple days ago I got some stats during
the first day it was downloaded more
than a million times within less than 24
hours that's [ __ ] insane
I beat Kim K's shitty app it beat the
[ __ ] out of Pokemon go I am so proud of
you bros couldn't have done it better
myself
and the app is still growing and we just
feel incredibly humbled by you bruh
support and everyone playing the game we
never expected this and we just wanted
to say thank you and by we I mean out of
minds who worked on the game they made a
little video let's check it out
hey guys millions of people are now
playing the game and it's absolutely
crazy
it's incredible creative you're with
your room and we love watching damn so
here's the whole other life theme we're
just an event so big thanks we've been
working on this game for a little less
than a year and the original idea came
out to do a pewdiepie sim a youtuber
simulator because there weren't any at
the time okay then all these other one
came out and stole my likeness but now
we have an actual one and it's actually
good it's obvious all for saying it but
it is a lot of work to get something
like this out there it is a very very
long process and a lot of time and a lot
of work went into it especially from out
of mines obviously they I'm so thankful
for all the hard work they put into it
the fact that you both are enjoying it
means more
anything at this point the fight seeing
so many of you bros playing the game
having fun with it I think that's
incredible and it feels so fantastic to
have a product out that you bros really
really really enjoy I'm really really
proud of that and I'm really really
proud of out of minds that being said we
are gonna update the game we are gonna
keep adding features to it and we're
gonna keep you guys entertained if you
haven't checked out the game already I
recommend you do so right now we have a
lot of plans for the game the online
features are gonna be added soon when
the game launched there were over almost
half a million people playing it at the
same time and our poor servers who are
basically fried potatoes at this point
they were just [ __ ]
they were completely [ __ ] so we're
still working on getting the online
features back autumn eyes literally
slept at their studio just to kind of
get things back working it is still just
a small studio it's not like a [ __ ]
triple-a thing and we're still
outperforming all these big companies
which is really cool I'm really really
proud of that I'm still fine and Canada
can't get over the fact that sleepy took
a [ __ ] twice you've you kind of have
that koala Shing that feeling here that
you want to throw up but you're kind of
keeping it and trying to keep composed
you know all of my keyboard so while the
servers are being fixed I am announcing
a competition for you Bros for the next
week if you have the game I want you to
post a screenshot of you your set up and
make it funny make it something that
would make me laugh that's all I want to
post it in the link in the description
but take a screenshot and post it there
and I will review them for another time
and the winners will get get this guy's
verified was that the winners will yeah
verify just don't spam the forums jesus
[ __ ] christ
are you spamming the forums yes you are
spamming the forums stop spam it affirm
I just got the image of the liquid
coming out of slippies [ __ ] and it
just won't go away if you want to add
each other in the game I recommend using
the hashtag
cheaver simulator and I recommend
checking out the forum talk to other
people do not create a separate [ __ ]
thread Jesus Christ stop doing that
yeah that's that's what I want you to do
that being said you bros [ __ ]
kick-ass Jesus I'm so impressed I have a
million followers in the game it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can't believe that
this is happening I'm so happy I feel so
lucky your brothers are [ __ ] awesome
thank you for playing the game now keep
playing it because we're gonna be
[ __ ] rich I'm kidding not even making
that much money of the game hahaha
hahaha but yeah that's it for me for now
check out the check out super simulators
in the description and I would kiss my
hands but I can't you know it's like me
are you gonna be okay are you gonna be
okay for the outro I think maybe I am I
squeezed his belly a bit too hard you
know don't [ __ ] oh he's doing that thing
again I'm holding him like this now
alright slippy you take the outro please
don't [ __ ]
please don't [ __ ] I'm looking at
straight at his [ __ ]
oh alright he's gonna [ __ ] he's gonna
[ __ ] it's gonna [ __ ]
[Music]
take a [ __ ] bath you [ __ ] [ __ ]
they don't tell you this in totes kewl
[Music]